have you guys ever heard of Nagi Harris  he's in real my dad told me that was all  made up no he's real let you said that  he was half man and half horse  everything that he came in contact was  was destroyed guys are crazy he's an  urban legend no one has ever seen I have  no no you have yes I have I've seen him  train late at night he didn't know I saw  him but I did he turns after midnight so  no one can see him he's the biggest  football player I've ever seen he'll run  past you before you even know it and  never look him in the eye ever why not  whose eyes are piercing alas kid that's  our training we missing  I was lucky I got away  yeah right you're making this up no one  has ever seen him Nagi is an urban  legend Matt they never found the kid  do you think that's him  you